so continuing the trend of running over
the upcoming titles for all-new
all-different marvel in this video I
wanted to focus on Wolverine the x-men
the Inhumans and selection of other
characters one thing I'd like to point
out is that unlike the Avengers and
spider-man none of the other titles
we'll be talking about here have zero
issues instead these publications pick
up from their stories prior to Secret
Wars with all-new all-different titles
providing jumping-off points for those
who are new to Marvel Comics all new
Wolverine is written by Tom Taylor and
will see Laura Kenney also known as x-23
take over the mantle of Wolverine from
James Howlett following the pre Secret
Wars story the death of Wolverine which
had killed him off while the details are
extremely hard to come by and an
interview with come above resources
writer Tom Taylor was very hush-hush and
only went so far is to say that x-23
would play a peacemaker between two
factions in her first arch and that the
emphasis will be put on her past at a
later date old man Logan will return in
all-new all-different marvel and will be
written by Jeff Lemire and an interview
with marvel.com Jeff Lemire had stated
that old man Logan will pick up with the
original old man Logan and the old man
Logan secret worst high-end serving as
part of the basis behind Logan's life
well the first few comics will see a lot
of cameos like the tie-in from Secret
Wars the all-new all-different old man
Logan will provide readers with a tour
de france of the various teams and
factions in the new universe
transitioning to the x-men under did
it's hopeless the characters from the
pre secret war stories of all new x-men
will returned with x-23 standing in for
Wolverine and an interview with comic
book resources Dennis hopeless had
stated that the series will initially be
presented with the all-new x-men at odds
with the rest of the x-men team which
will result in a roadtrip of sorts as
the group tries to figure out their
place in the world uncanny x-men is a
title geared towards older x-men fans
written by : bond and with a roster
composed of magneto psylocke phantom x
mystique and Sabretooth in another
interview with comic book resources :
Bunn had stated that the team would
expand in number as a publication
continued and that with the roster
largely composed of anti-heroes the best
way to look at the team is as the
Brotherhood of Evil Mutants upholding
Xavier stream
I'd spend ninety to will return post
Secret Wars under the writing of Chris
Sims and we'll focus on a series of
stories outside of the existing
continuity that will maintain the same
feel as a story during Secret Wars as
well as the x-men the animated series
from the 1990s extraordinary x-men is
being written by Jeff Lemire as well and
will stand as Marvel's flagship x-men
title with a roster compose a storm
Nightcrawler young Jean Grey old man
Logan Iceman magic and Colossus the
initial stories will focus on a rift
that formed between P and humans at the
x-men during the eight months after the
end of secret wars in the beginning of
all-new all-different marvel getting
into the Inhumans uncanny Inhumans will
be written by Charles Soule during an
interview with Mashable Charles Soule
had stated to the comment will continue
many of the trends seen in the initial
launch of the series prior to Secret
Wars including the relationship between
Johnny Storm and Medusa as well as the
arrival of new Inhumans throughout the
publication history all new and humans
will be written by Charles Soule as well
with a roster composed of Krystal
Corrigan Flint Naja and grid as he
explained to Marvel comm all new
Inhumans will focus more on Ovilus that
have appeared around the world and
amplify the abilities of existing
Inhumans while the information is
ambiguous at best the issue of the
Ovilus will play a major role in the
beginning of the series Karnak will be
written by Warren Ellis and focus on the
fact that the title character had lived
among the Inhumans but was never exposed
to the Terrigen mists while the
information on this comic is also
ambiguous during an interview with
chemical resources Warren Ellis had
stated that using this as a foundation
the story will focus on karnak's
philosophy and intelligence as a way to
find the flaw and everything invincible
Iron Man will be written by Brian
Michael Bendis and sinner on a Tony
Stark who isn't as rich as he used to be
and it's created a new type of armor for
himself with new powers in addition to
this according to an interview with
ventus the story will also feature a new
love interest who maybe starts
intellectual equal or superior as well
as a fifteen-year-old kid from MIT who's
been able to duplicate his armor
astonishing ant-man is written by Nick
Spencer and will have the same feel as
ant-man vol 1 prior to Secret Wars and
during an interview with the LA Times
Nick Spencer had stated the series would
emphasize Scott Lang's view of his
daughter Cassie as well as the balancing
act between being a superhero and being
a father angela queen of hell is being
written by Margaret Bennett and will
focus on Angela the sister of Loki and
Thor as she rules the realm of Hell one
of the nine realms of Asgard all new
Hawkeye will pick up from the pre secret
war series focusing on Clint Barton the
original Hawkeye and Kate Bishop the new
Hawkeye according to an interview by
writer Jeff Lemire at the San Diego
comic-con panel the story will have a
feel similar to old man Logan with the
series jumping back and forth between
future events and present events
regarding both Clint and Kate agents of
shield is being written by Mike
Guggenheim and will serve as a companion
comic to the television series of the
same name and while it will take place
at an alternate reality
it'll also see expansions on characters
like agent May Deathlok and others
vision is being written by Tom King and
will serve as a back-to-basics story of
the vision on a personal level the comic
will also see the introduction of a
vision family as well as the information
surrounding why this was done and how
vision views himself in relation to all
of them Jason Aaron will be returning
for the Mighty Thor which will continue
with Jane Foster in the title role as
well as how she copes with the Civil War
within a scarred proper during an
interview with Comic Book Resources
Jason Aaron had also stated that he
intended to explain the mystery of what
it was that Nick Fury had sent a Thor
during the original sin event totally
awesome hope will be written by Greg Pak
and see the introduction of Amadeus Cho
as the new Hulk however during a
conversation I had with Greg Pak during
Baltimore Comic Con he had mentioned
that the series will also answer the
question of what happened to Bruce
Banner and whether or not he will ever
become the Hulk again and finally
Captain Marvel will return under Tara
butters and see Carol Danvers teaming up
with Alpha Flight and functioning as
more of a space superhero in the same
fashion as the original Captain Marvel
prior to his death and 1982 with that
being said we're gonna bring this video
to an end and I will catch you guys on
it peace